We are expecting our first eight,
Evan says,
we are expecting our first child in May a daughter.
Any specific,
any advice specific to raising daughters?
Well,
congratulations first,
so that's great.
Um,
okay.
Let's see.
I'm just thinking about my daughter and specific advice.
I would say don't be afraid to support her masculine and feminine sides,
you know,
and so the feminine side is you'll find little girls.
Now,
not all little girls because some are more masculine than others,
but let's say you have a more feminine little girl.
She's going to like to dress up and she's going to like to put on jewelry.
It's amazing how much of that stuff seems to be implicit or a Nate,
you know,
and that can be really supported.
But then by the same token,
it's nice to wrestle with your little girl kids and little kids really like
rough and tumble play into and to,
you know,
encourage her to be courageous and forthright.
And so if you're lucky you can,
you can support her in both elements of her personality and that would be a
really good thing to do.
So
don't let her wrap.
Are you around her little finger either?
That's another thing too.